my comfort food is cheese dog corned
beef garlic rice with egg I learned how
to cook this meal on my own growing up
in the Philippines probably around eight
to ten years old I learned from just
watching family and relatives clucked it
gives me joy because it reminds me of
the simpler times so we got hot dogs
looking for the cheese dog I don't know
if it's this is if this is the right one
because this one looks weird but it says
it's got cheese in it some corned beef I
used to think corned beef has some corn
in it got rice whole lotta rice would
feed a whole family with this got eggs
garlic and onions for the rice and the
corned beef pours secret sauce banana
ketchup
[Music]
first things first right you wash it
because sometimes a little dirty if you
want to measure it you just need your
finger you measure the rice first then
after that you measure from the top of
the rice and the water level should be
basically twice the height of the rice
does that make sense
that's it then you put it in here turn
it on and we wait it's like magic it's
for sneaking a drain
I think didn't you start cooking it chop
the onion
yeah it's getting into my eyes garlic
the corned beef I like these cans cuz
they could just use a key and twist it
looks kind of nasty but tastes great
like this so I'm gonna put my corned
beef yeah just drop that in there that's
too much go back in smush it up send
this just kind of put a couple looks
like rice in the Philippines we have
rice as the base for any kind of meal
and everything else that you put on top
of rice is called Coulomb which is the
English word for it as buying I believe
I don't know what it's called buy in and
Tagalog it's called Coulomb which is
everything else that you put on top of
rice but he's a one hand
Oh mother Oh I was lucky oh wait this
isn't on garlic so now I'm gonna scoop
some rice and that's about it when I eat
my comfort food I love to sit on the
floor by this coffee table on the edge
because I could just lean on this couch
and watch the TV you know when you have
that spot on the couch
I have a spot on the floor okay here's
the thing I don't know if that's a
cheese dog then see if there's cheese in
time good wait wait I was looking for a
hot dog would she little cheese dripping
down from the inside of it but I chose
the wrong one like it I could see what's
coming through very all comforting
flavors you haven't tried it with the
banana cat
so this is just try it
[Music]
it's like ketchup but a little more
acidic sweet sweet it's not what you
would think what banana yeah right I
want it what this reminds me of is my
childhood and part of it is like friends
and relatives back in the Philippines
where we used to just run around play
outside and also having to pray before
every single meal with my family
[Music]
what do you want
you are